bonjour vous allez poursuivre dans un
instant l'audition de nadjaf vallaud
belkacem devant la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat la ministre
des droits des femmes présentent un
projet de loi pour lutter contre les
inégalités persistantes entre femmes et
hommes
parmi les mesures phare du texte inciter
davantage d'hommes à prendre un congé
parental congé parental qui aujourd'hui
est prise à 97% par les femmes
autres mesures du gouvernement lutter
contre les violences conjugales
enfin un mécanisme de garantie contre
les impayés de pension alimentaire va
être expérimenté dans certaines caisses
d'allocations familiales voilà ce texte
sera examiné à partir de septembre au
sénat
donc madame la ministre vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président émile
excuses pour ce petit retard je vais
essayer de faire court parce que l'idée
c'est vraiment qu'on soit dans les
changes
donc on d'abord merci d'avoir accepté de
travailler en effet à cette période très
chargée sur un texte qui devrait venir
devant vous durant la première semaine
de reprise des travaux au sénat qui est
un texte portant sur les droits des
femmes qu'on a choisi d'intituler projet
de loi égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes qui est un texte qui se veut très
transversal qui considère que pour mieux
contrer les inégalités qui se manifeste
un peu partout dans la société et bien
il faut s'intéresser à chacune de ces
inégalités entre les hommes et les
femmes et y apporter un certain nombre
de réponses et donc contrairement au
précédent texte de loi qui ont vu le
jour sur les droits des femmes on n'est
pas sur un thème précis violences faites
aux femmes égalité professionnelle on
est sur l'ensemble ce texte
il comporte quatre volets différents le
premier égalité professionnelle le
second précarité des femmes le troisième
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes est le quatrième parité
s'agissant d'égalité professionnelle
pour résumer les dispositions nouvelles
que nous introduisons nous veillons à
donner davantage d'effectivité aux lois
existantes déjà s'agissant de les
obligations en matière d'égalité
professionnelle pour les entreprises de
plus de 50 salariés
en introduisant notamment l'idée que
désormais une entreprise depuis de 50
salariés qui ne se conformeraient pas à
ses obligations égalité professionnelle
ne pourrait plus soumissionner à un
marché public
c'est une mesure qui a vocation à être
très dissuasive
même si on y reviendra sans doute dans
les questions évidemment nous l'avons
conçu de façon relativement
proportionnée pour ne pas non plus nuire
à l'activité des pme cela va de soi mais
on y reviendra si vous voulez en détail
donc première chose donnée de
l'effectivité aux obligations existantes
en matière d'égalité professionnelle
avec cette mesure dissuasive
deuxième chose toujours dans le volet
égalité professionnelle la nouveauté du
texte dont vous avez sans doute déjà
entendu parler c'est la réforme du congé
parental
considérant que beaucoup des inégalités
dans le monde du travail entre les
hommes et les femmes s'explique par
l'inégal répartition des tâches
domestiques et des responsabilités
parentales entre les hommes et les
femmes
nous nous sommes attaqués à ce volet là
du congé parental qui aujourd'hui est
pris à 97% par les femmes qui lorsqu'il
est pris sur une longue durée porte
préjudice de façon évidente en termes de
décrochage salariale en terme de non
accès à des promotions et des
responsabilités aux femmes et donc nous
rappelons un principe simple c'est que
le congé parental c'est fait pour les
mères comme pour les pères et pour mieux
donner corps à ce principe simple et
bien nous créons une incitation très
forte pour le 2ème parents de prendre
six mois au sein du congé parental
lorsqu'il y a un enfant dans le couple
ce sont six mois que nous rajoutons par
rapport à l'existant aujourd'hui on
pouvait prendre six mois en tout et bien
nous rajoutons six mois de plus à
condition qu'ils soient pris par le
deuxième par an lorsqu'il y a deux
enfants et plus dans le couple
les six mois en question devront être
pris au sein de l'ensemble des trois ans
existant actuellement nécessairement par
le deuxième par an donc réforme du congé
parental qui s'accompagnera d'un certain
nombre de dispositifs on y reviendra
aussi dans les questions pour mieux
accompagner en particulier les maires à
la fin de leur congé parental par de la
formation par un bilan de compétences
par un accompagnement personnalisé à
l'emploi puisqu'on sait dans quelles
difficultés elles se trouvent
généralement surtout lorsqu'elles ne
sont pas l'emploi en emploi à la base
pour retrouver une activité
pour finir sur ce volet égalité
professionnelle
nous transposerons nous sommes en train
de le faire également dans la loi
l'accord qui a été négocié entre les
partenaires sociaux sur ce sujet et qui
prévoit un certain nombre de mesures qui
renforceront notre système notamment
pour que les salariés qui reviennent
d'un congé parental soient mieux pris en
considération dans l'entreprise qu'ils
aient la possibilité d'aménager leurs
horaires s'il le souhaite que hills et
là encore un bilan de compétences qui
permettent qu'ils ne soient pas lésés
par leur absence leur interruption etc
deuxième volet du texte donc la
précarité des femmes avec un sujet
auquel on s'est intéressé de plus près
qui est la question des impayés de
pension alimentaire puisqu'on sait que
c'est très fréquent 40% de pension
alimentaire soit pas payé soit payé
régulièrement que très souvent on est
dans la situation d'une mère isolée avec
un ou plusieurs enfants qui tombent
souvent dans la précarité du fait de cet
impayé est donc plutôt que de les
laisser ces mères isolées continue à se
débrouiller seuls pour récupérer leur dû
ont créé une espèce de garantie publique
contre les impayés de pension
alimentaire avec un acteur central qui
est la caf la caisse d'allocations
familiales qui fera désormais cran entre
les deux parents et qui lorsqu une
pension alimentaire n'aura pas été versé
et ce dès le premier mois c'est ça
toutes les nouveautés qu'on introduit se
substituera pour verser à la mairie
isoler une allocation de soutien
familial
qui est amené à voir son menton montant
augmente et qui sera donc de près de 120
euros par enfant et par mois puis la caf
se débrouille pour se retourner ensuite
contre le débiteur défaillant et
recouvrer son dû et on lui donne les
moyens de le faire car il nous semble
important de ne pas créer des
incitations à verser sa pension
alimentaire non plus évidemment
troisième volet du texte la lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes
on avait déjà beaucoup de choses dans la
loi et notamment grâce au travail que
vous avez fourni ces dernières années
mais en même temps il y avait des choses
à combler ou à améliorer et donc ce que
nous introduisons de nouveau en matière
de protection des victimes de violences
faites aux femmes
c'est la généralisation du téléphone
portable grand danger à l'ensemble du
territoire je ne reviens pas sur ce que
c'est je pense que vous le connaissez
bel outil de protection des femmes qui a
fait ses preuves là où il a été
expérimenté donc nous généralisons nous
écrivons dans le marbre de la loi le
principe de l'éviction du foyer du
conjoint violent et pas le contraire
parce que dans l'immense majorité des
cas aujourd'hui c'est que ça reste la
victime qui doit se trouver une solution
d'hébergement
nous mettons fin à la pratique de la
médiation pénale lorsqu'on est face à
une situation de violence conjugale
parce qu'on sait que la victime et le
coupable ne sont pas sur un pied
d'égalité et que cette pratique est
assez délétère dans les effets qu'elle
produit nous faisons nous nous
intéressons aux femmes victimes de
violences étrange et enfin aux femmes
étrangères victimes de violences pour
lesquelles vous savez que le principe
c'était déjà depuis quelques années que
lorsqu'elles sont victimes de violences
avérées
eh bien on leur permettait d'obtenir ou
de renouveler leur titre de séjour sans
difficulté sauf que jusqu'à présent
demeurer des taxes assez importante de
plusieurs centaines d'euros à payer pour
l'obtention ou le renouvellement de ce
type de séjour alors on met fin à cet
axe pour ces femmes étrangères victimes
de violences pour finalement faciliter
la sortie du cycle de violence et
enlever tous les freins possibles
ça c'est pour le meilleur protection des
femmes pour ce qui est des auteurs des
violences il nous a semblé très
important d'aller plus loin que ce que
fait notre loi aujourd'hui en termes de
suivi des auteurs avec la création d'un
dispositif nous
que nous avons intitulé stage de
prévention de la récidive pour les
auteurs de violences conjointe de
violences faites aux femmes
ces stages ils ont une vertu pédagogique
c'est à dire que à un moment donné on se
rend compte que très souvent les auteurs
de violence sont dans le déni y compris
des années après par rapport aux actes
qu'ils ont commis et donc si on veut
éviter la récidive et bien il faut les
mettre face à la gravité des actes
qu'ils ont commis gravité pour leurs
victimes elles mêmes bien entendu mais
aussi gravité pour leurs enfants qui ont
pu être témoins etc
et donc ces stages seront désormais
comment dire imposer aux auteurs de
violences à leurs frais soit en qualité
de peine complémentaire soit en qualité
de peines alternatives
je clôture la le volet violence et j'en
viens au dernier volet du texte qui est
le volet parité donc là deux principes
simples le premier c'est que en matière
de vie politique
on renforce les pénalités est liée au
non respect de la parité par les parties
dans les élections législatives donc en
fait on double le taux de modulation
financière pour le dire autrement on
double la pénalité financière qui
s'impose au parti qui respecte pas cette
parité et le deuxième principe c'est que
on étend le champ de la parité à des
secteurs qui en était jusqu alors un
petit peu exonérés ou pas concernés qui
sont tout aussi bien les fédérations
sportives les chambres de commerce et
d'industrie les chambres d'agriculture
les autorités administratives
indépendantes les établissements publics
industriels et commerciaux
ça fait beaucoup beaucoup de structures
on pourra entrer aussi dans le détail si
vous avez des questions voilà
normalement j'ai à peu près fini et je
vais m'arrêter là si peut-être juste un
point pardon un point quand même on agit
aussi sur la question des médias je
crois que c'est important à souligner
puisque tous ceux qui s'intéressent un
petit peu au sujet évidemment des
inégalités hommes femmes comprennent
bien qu'elles trouvent leurs racines
dans un certain nombre de stéréotypes
qui sont diffusées confortée notamment
par les médias et donc nous donnons une
nouvelle compétence au conseil supérieur
de l'audiovisuel csa pour qu'il puisse
non seulement veiller à ce que les
médias audiovisuels
ne diffuse pas en permanence des images
attentatoire à la dignité des femmes
mais aller plus loin et veiller à ce que
ces images ne conforte pas ils ne
reproduisent pas stéréotypes avéré donc
c'est une question très intéressante
parce que vous me direz qu est-ce que
les stéréotypes qu'est ce que le sexisme
et bien il leur reviendra justement au
c'est ça qui est une autorité
indépendante de définir une grille
indicative avec une série de critères
qui font que on estime qu'un programme
est trop stéréotypé au point de les et
un sexe par rapport à un autre ou pas
voilà je crois que je vous ai à peu près
tout dit vous voyez que c'est un texte
vaste nous sommes vraiment je l' ai dit
à plusieurs reprises je le redis ici
dans la co construction avec le
parlement sur ce texte parce que je
crois qu'il ya beaucoup de choses qui
ont été pensés par les uns et les autres
donc nous accueillons avec le plus grand
intérêt évidemment les les améliorations
les ajouts que vous pourriez faire mais
l'idée c'est bien de rester sur une
réponse intégrée aux inégalités qui
elles mêmes sont assez intégrés merci
merci madame la ministre pour cet exposé
très très clairs et précis je vais
donner la parole à madame la présidente
annie david
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre merci pour votre présentation
et je vais simplement peut-être vous
indiquer que nous avons nommé michel
meunier comme rapporteur pour avis sur
ce texte que par essence nous somme
saisie que pour avis sur certains sujets
donc n'ayant pas pu se joindre à nous
pour cette audition je vais me permettre
de vous poser des questions qu'elle
avait qu'elle souhaitait vous poser pour
cette audition madame la ministre
donc concernant la réforme du congé
parental le gouvernement attendant que
de cette réforme du complément de libre
choix d'activité une augmentation du
taux de recours des pères à cette
prestation à l'image un peu de ce qui a
été observé en allemagne
à l'occasion d'une réforme également du
congé parental qui a été mise en oeuvre
elle en 2007
or cette réforme en allemagne n'est pas
tout à fait de même nature que celle qui
nous est proposé ici puisqu'elle a
constitué en la création d'un congé
parental plus court mais mieux rémunérés
donc dès lors sur quelles hypothèses
basées vous votre estimation de 100
mille paires qui pourrait éventuellement
être bénéficiaire du clc a donc ce
fameux complément d'activité pour 2010
est cette réforme nous dit michel
meunier de son point de vue va
mécaniquement créer des besoins
supplémentaires en termes de places
d'accueil des enfants les enfants de
moins de 3 ans j'entends et donc le plan
de création de places annoncées par le
premier ministre le 3 juin dernier
suffira t-il pensez-vous à couvrir ses
besoins nouveaux
concernant un peu plus la vie à
l'entreprise parce que là évidemment
c'était également l'égalité
professionnelle mais là pour le coup à
l'intérieur de l'entreprise les
partenaires sociaux ont conclu le 19
juin dernier un accord national
interprofessionnel intitulé vers une
politique d'amélioration de la qualité
de vie au travail et de l'égalité
professionnelle
quels sont donc les intentions du
gouvernement et quelles sont donc vos
intentions pour la transposition de
certaines des mesures qu'il prône comme
par exemple la réorganisation des
obligations de négociation en entreprise
en matière d'égalité professionnelle
d'égalité salariale ou encore en matière
de sécurisation des carrières des
salariés bénéficiant d'un congé parental
d'éducation
puisqu'on sait que ce sont très souvent
les femmes qui prennent ces congés etc
en effet quand elles reviennent dans
l'entreprise elles subissent un petit
peu les conséquences de leur absence
prolongée du fait de ce congé parental
ce congé parental d'éducation
voilà merci madame la ministre par
avance si madame david madame la
présidente brigitte gonthier maurin
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
ravi de pouvoir échanger avec vous sur
ce projet de loi je veux vous dire que
la commission que la délégation aux
droits des femmes a déjà procédé à de
nombreuses auditions et qu' il y a un
avis positif une réception tout à fait
positive sur la mise en chantier de ce
texte même si elle est bon il est
unanimement saluée même s'il ya des
attentes encore qui demeurent et
notamment une question vient très
fortement c'est celle de la nécessité de
l'égalité salariale de progresser
davantage en termes d'égalité salariale
pour évidemment à soir de façon beaucoup
plus fondamentale les questions de
l'égalité hommes femmes
un autre petit regret nous a été pointé
aussi sait mais on sait bien que nous
n'étions pas sur une loi cadre et que si
vous aviez affirmé la question de la
transversalité des inégalités de la
nécessité d'agir en transversalité sur
elle
nous n'étions pas en présence d'une loi
cas mais un deuxième petit sujet vient
c'est la nécessité d'avancer encore
davantage sur le droit de pouvoir
disposer de son corps et notamment la
question de la revalorisation de l'acte
dit vg vient très fortement mais nous
aurons l'occasion de vous en parler au
moment du plfss
bien entendu voilà je ferme le ban mais
comme madame la ministre vous avez
beaucoup fait pas appel au travail
parlementaire je veux vous dire que la
délégation aux droits des femmes va
saisir la perche et sera en mesure de
vous faire de nombreuses recommandations
qui je l'espère seront transformés en
propositions d'amendements que nous
portons de façon de façon large voilà il
y a
je crois un premier souci a détricoté si
je puis m'exprimer ainsi c'est de
montrer en quoi précisément ce projet de
loi et connexes avec d'autres projets de
loi et je pense notamment à la question
fondamentale de la déconstruction des
stéréotypes de genre et la place et le
rôle de l'éducation nationale tout le
monde ne voit pas les connexions et
évidemment il y a encore des choses qui
demeurent floues dans d'autres projets
de enfin doit maintenant puisque la loi
payons a été votée voilà d'une manière
générale la préoccupation de la
formation de tous les professionnels qui
interviennent dans le domaine de des
inégalités via avec l'exigence que cette
formation bien sûr traite
de l'amont des inégalités mais aussi de
laval et qu'elle puisse être réalisé de
façon conséquente c'est à dire par pas
n'importe qui c'est à dire des
professionnels formés donc évidemment on
commence à avoir des réponses comment
sur comment tout cela pourrait se
scénarise et mais je crois qu'il y
aurait dans le propos à mieux explicités
à la fois l'exigence que que vous portez
que nous partageons et comment cela va
se réaliser
voilà je vais pas en dire beaucoup plus
je peut pointer une inquiétude bien sûr
nous avons repéré le rôle du csa et nous
ferons des recommandations de ce point
de vue là parce que vous dites il y aura
une grille je pense qu'on va vous
proposer de mettre sur pied nous pas
d'observatoire parce que je sais que
vous diffusiez non on va rusé on va vous
demandez peut-être de regarder pour
travailler sur une mission d'observation
à la fois sur les programmes mais aussi
sur comment se construisent l'accès aux
responsabilités dans les chaînes et au
csa lui même voilà je chantais remirent
est une terminerai par une petite
inquiétude sur lequel nous serons
particulièrement vigilants parce qu'elle
vient aussi de façon importante mais je
ne doute pas que vous ayez songer c'est
la question des moyens d'une manière
globale
voilà il y a ensuite dans le déroulé de
l'examen du projet de loi
d
expressions qui font souci la notion les
meilleurs délais lorsqu'il va s'agir de
la délivrance de l' ordonnance de
protection
on comprend bien le souci qui mais bon
quelle est la valeur juridique
datel le câble nous avons je crois aussi
à être interpellé sur la question des
places d'hébergement
donc nous vous ferons aussi des
propositions de recommandation dans ce
sens là annie david a balayé ce qu'il
est ce qu'il allait découler de la de
l'accord qui vient d'être pris avec des
organisations syndicales
est ce que le gouvernement aura des
amendements comment on peut aider aussi
à avancer à identifier des questions sur
l'égalité professionnelle
et puis j'en termine sur eu vraiment une
toute dernière question c'est évidemment
ce qui va être les moyens qui vont être
générés par les six mois qui pourrait
être reversée au pot commun entre
guillemets s'ils ne sont pas pris par le
père on voudrait avoir vraiment
l'assurance que tout cela sera bien
affectée à la création de places de
crèche
là aussi ça va pas être facile parce
qu'on va pas avoir de retour avant
plusieurs mois et le temps de
construction d'une crèche n'est pas
toujours compatible donc comment
allons-nous pouvoir nasa / est de ceux
là
bon voila un petit peu l'état d'esprit
mais en tout cas nous nous avons bien
l'intention d'être très très très actif
à la délégation et le rapport sera prêt
dès lundi prochain
voilà
la présidente madame virginie klès
rapporteur oui merci monsieur présent je
vais être courte pour laisser du temps
pour les autres intervenants quelques
questions qu'ils reviendront évidemment
autour des violences faites aux femmes
l'hébergement vient d'être
vient d'être souligné il faudra aussi
penser à l'hébergement des conjoints
évincé parce que laisser la femme dans
son logement nécessite de loger quelque
part et dans un endroit approprié le
conjoint violent donc il faudra y penser
en matière d' ordonnance de protection
pénale je pense que la commission aura
également des amendements à vous
soumettre
peut-être pour étendre cette ordonnance
de protection à la famille et donc aux
enfants qui sont qui peuvent se
retrouver menacé dans un certain nombre
de cas au moins dans leur intégrité
psychique la notification certes les
délais mais comment fait-on pour les
respecter ce qu'il faut être très
strictes ou pas sur les délais justement
ou laisser la formule meilleurs délais
les professeurs que j'ai entendues sont
plutôt solides et de la souplesse
aujourd'hui mais comment faire en ce cas
là pour les aider à améliorer les délais
les raccourcir et puis ce mélange de
civils et de pénal un conte soulève
depuis le début qui n'est pas un
obstacle en soi mais qu'il faut prendre
le temps de décortiquer c'est un juge
civil qui prononce une mesure pénale
dont il n'a pas l'habitude il n'a pas
les pouvoirs pour prononcer une enquête
pour lancer une enquête
donc comment peut-on faire pour donner
le relais à la chaîne pénale à ce moment
là pour faire valider peut-être une
décision du juge civil par le parquet je
sais pas mais a sans doute des choses à
à étudier sur ce plan là sur le plan de
la protection aussi des femmes et des
enfants victimes de violences ou des
hommes ça arrive aussi victimes de
violences je me pose la question du
secret professionnel et de cette
barrière qu'il y aujourd'hui entre le
secret professionnel d'un côté et la non
assistance à personne en danger de
l'autre comment faire pour faire bouger
un petit peu les frontières sans faire
complètement basculé un équilibre qui
est celui de notre société aujourd'hui
mais en apportant une meilleure
protection aux victimes
on aura d'autres d'autres questions et
d'autres sujets encore abordé sur ce sur
ce thème des violences pour être serein
thématique peut-être un petit peu moins
préoccupante en termes de parité
est ce que la parité doit
systématiquement est toujours être 50 50
à l'unité près ou est-ce qu' elle ne
peut pas se jouer sous la forme d'une
fourchette est ce que la fourchette doit
être 40 60 55 45
il ya là aussi des questions à se poser
et pour tous qui instances
représentatives d'une partie de la
société que ce soit champ des métiers
champ de l'agriculture fédérations
sportives
et c est ce qu il ne faut pas mieux
prendre en compte la sociologie de
l'instance qui est représenté est ce
qu'il faut pousser pour qu'il y ait plus
de femmes ou plus d'hommes selon les cas
ça arrive aussi même si c'est moins
fréquent dans ses instances la faim dans
la société avant de pousser aussi est la
représentativité dans les instances
représentatives autrement dit ce qu'il
faut prendre du temps prendre des étapes
où est-ce qu'il faut continuer sur le
chemin tel que vous le proposer ce sont
vraiment des questions que l'on se pose
est que l'on se posera avec vous pour en
terminer la loi bien évidemment j'y
souscris bien évidemment je pense
qu'elle est nécessaire et qu'elle sera
utile mais je pense aussi qu'il va
falloir beaucoup travailler et la scéno
travail à toutes et à tous pour changer
aussi la mentalité et s'éviter parfois
quelques propos quelques répliques ce
match il y compris de 27 ans simple
alors merci eu madame le rapporteur
le g3 s'inscrit madame dit ni madame
tasca monsieur mohamed soual y est at il
d'autres inscrits monsieur des plans
bien
alors madame muguette dini
si monsieur le président moi je voudrais
remercier notre ministre d'avoir
concocté un projet de loi aussi complet
aussi complémentaires et je ne vais pas
revenir sur ce qu'on dit mes collègues
parce que bien entendu je suis d'accord
avec elle votre loi est formidable mais
je suis sûr qu'on va pouvoir apporter
notre petite touche complémentaires qui
va faire de cette loi une vraie
merveille
je voulais je voulais revenir madame la
ministre sur l'allocation de congé
parental
j'avais eu l'occasion d'aborder la
question avec vous moi je suis
absolument d'accord avec le fait qu'il
faut que les pères participent à ce
congé parental il n'empêche que en
fonction du temps alloué
actuellement ces trois ans ce temps pose
quelques fois des problèmes à dc souvent
des mamans qui prennent ce congé
parental
si le congé parental s'arrête quelques
mois si l'enfant à trois ans quelques
mois avant la rentrée scolaire
il y a une difficulté pour trouver une
place d'accueil pour l'enfant cette
difficulté est compliqué beaucoup plus
compliqué quand il s'agit de parents de
multiples jumeaux triplés pour les
quadruples et y'en à feu donc j'en
parlerai pas mais pour ceux qui ont des
enfants plusieurs enfants en même temps
c'est très compliqué de trouver une
place d'accueil entre les 3 ans de
l'enfant et la rentrée donc la question
que je puis le deuxième élément c'est
que souvent pas toujours si c'est la
maman qui s'arrête c'est parce que c'est
elle qui a le salaire le moins élevé
donc comment vont être régler ces
questions de déséquilibres budgétaires
familiale si le papa s'arrête et que
même si l'on a la volonté mais que ça
pose des questions financières
est ce que il y a quelle pourrait être
la prise
la prise en charge des enfants qui n'ont
pas trois ans à la rentrée scolaire et
et enfin et serait-il possible à ce
moment-là d'allonger pour certains le
congé parental parce que la difficulté
pour les mamans ou les papas qui
s'arrêtent trois ans c'est qu'au bout de
trois ans ils peuvent être licenciés en
toute légalité
donc ou bien vous trouver une place pour
votre enfant ou bien vous perdez votre
emploi
alors c'est pas toujours parce que
quelquefois avec l'entreprise dont vous
êtes le salarié vous pouvez vous
arranger mais c'est en tout cas c'est
une possibilité et je crois que c'est
une vraie question
donc je voulais seulement poser cette
question là puisque toutes les autres
questions déjà été évoquée je les
partage
merci qui madame dit ni madame catherine
tasca
si monsieur le président j'abonde
derrière les propos de notre collègue
diguiny c'est une loi vraiment non
seulement nécessaire mais très très
bienvenus bravo madame la ministre
j'avais prévu de vous poser deux
questions l'une et je rebondis sur ce
qui vient d'être dit sur le clc à il y a
un vrai problème sur la réduction du
droit aux trois ans de congé parental
ça a été très bien décrit c'est à dire
que ça ne s'inscrit pas forcément dans
le calendrier d'entrée des enfants dans
un dans une structure d'accueil
j'ajoute aussi j'ai un peu un doute sur
le caractère incitatif auprès des des
pères dans la mesure où leurs six mois
doivent être pris sur l' enveloppe
globale des trois ans il me sente roduit
un un élément de débat au sein du couple
peut être qu'on ne facilite pas dans la
mesure où ça n'est pas un plus mais
c'est pris sur le temps global alloué
donc ça ne facilitera pas à mon avis le
choix bon est-ce que vous entrevoyez une
une porte de sortie qui permettrait de
mieux faire coller le retour de la maman
dans dans le circuit professionnel avec
les capacités des structures d'accueil
et est ce que il est encore envisageable
que la mesure concernant l'autre par an
soit une mesure réellement incitatif
c'est-à-dire qu'ils viennent en plus et
pas en réduction ma deuxième remarque a
déjà été posée par annie david et michel
meunier
c'est la question de l'égalité salariale
je crois qu'elle est fondamental qu'il
n'est pas possible à mon avis que votre
texte ne fasse pas mention explicitement
d'une manière ou d'une autre
donc qu'est ce que vous envisagez de
deux d'inscrire compte tenu de la
négociation entre les partenaires
sociaux
mais je crois que ce serait vraiment
très dommage que dans un texte penser
aussi globalement la question de
l'égalité salariale ne soit pas présente
je rappelle d'ailleurs que ici au sénat
une proposition de loi avait été déposé
et adopté 16 février 2012 sur cette
question de l'égalité salariale avec des
mesures précises à l'encontre des
entreprises qui ne négocient pas un
accord relatif à l'égalité salariale un
tank
comment est ce qu'on peut déjà inscrire
sa dent dans le texte puis une troisième
interrogation tout à fait ponctuel est
ce que l'article 18 ne constitue pas un
cavalier législatif je n'ai pas bien vu
ce qu était la raison de sa présence
dans ce texte
ça concerne le financement des campagnes
etc
article 18
oui voilà une merci madame d'ascq à
monsieur thani mohamed soilihi
oui merci monsieur le président et merci
madame la ministre de votre exposé deux
sets de ce projet de loi qui me paraît
moi aussi complet voire voire très
ambitieux à chaque fois qu'une qu'une
loi qu'un projet de loi vient auprès des
deux assemblées
nous nous demandons dans nos territoires
reculés
comment il va se décliner et à ce qui me
concerne à ce qui concerne mon
département
les questions sont bien en amont je veux
parler bien évidemment des raisons
fondamentales structurelles qui font
qu'ils les inégalités hommes femmes
persiste je parlais de l'instruction
l'accès à l'éducation l'accès à la
formation des jeunes filles la situation
est déjà sérieuses et déjà problématique
pour l'ensemble de la population encore
plus pour la gente la gente féminine et
c'est pour ça que je pose la question
est ce que à l'occasion de cette loi
vous envisagez de donner un coup de
boost pour permettre un meilleur accès à
la formation à l'instruction et à la
formation et à l'éducation des jeunes
filles pour enfin sortir de ce de ce
cercle infernal à mayotte
la polygamie a été supprimé l'inégalité
successeur elle a été supprimée la
parité hommes-femmes a été instauré la
loi de 2001 s'applique et pour autant
ces inégalités j'ai peur qu'elle est
encore de beaux jours devant elle
si on ne s'attaque pas à la racine du
problème
doux
d'où mon interrogation merci merci je
dirais à tanis que son territoire n'est
absolument pas reculer que mayotte est
un département chère à notre coeur et
qui fait partie voilà éloignés mais pas
éloigné de notre coeur ni d'ailleurs de
notre raison bien alors félix desplan
oui mais si madame la ministre vous
aussi d'exposer pour nous avoir confié
des éléments de vous proposer de loi
selon moi madame la ministre
l'inégalité entre les femmes et les
hommes trouve sa source dans la
différence de l'éducation qui a donné
aux filles et aux garçons
chez moi la guadeloupe présenti même ici
une autre société n'est pas aussi
distinctement ok que celle de mayotte
nous disons qu'on lui met beaucoup de
familles ont dit et parler de leurs
garçons ils disent mes co mais comme les
cochons libre c'est aux femmes de
retenir leurs poulets tu vas images ça
veut dire que dans une famille
l'éducation qui est donné aux garçons
étaient telles que dès le départ il ya
une priorité il y a un ascendant sur la
fille est donc c'est d'abord tout le
monde éducation dans la famille je sais
que ce sera difficile d'être venu à
chaque famille mais il faut qu'un autre
société parviennent à corriger cela il
faudrait voir à l'école effectivement
veiller à ce que cette éducation puisse
former des les jeunes à des régionales
d'une jeune âge à ceux qui aiment les
garçons et les filles se considère comme
un égo pour penser problèmes d'éducation
parce que les mesures que vous avez à
nos célèbres sont très importantes
mais à mon avis elles sont coercitives
qu'elles sont dissuasives
il faut que nous parvenions à agir très
tôt au niveau des enfants pour qu'ils ne
soient éduqués qu'il grandisse cet
esprit là ensuite d'autres choses vous
avez parlé de l'intervention de la kfor
au cas où des hommes ne veut pas faire
dans la mesure et qui sait fréquentent
les hommes ne paye pas les ne verse pas
les passions alimentaire donc la caf et
intervenir il avait aussi quelque chose
à compensation et vous savez que
beaucoup d'hommes dans ce cas l'un
arrive à organiser leur solvabilité
alors cela veut dire que à la longue on
pourrait créer des problèmes au niveau
de la caf
si on n'arrive pas effectivement à dix
on a récupéré chez les uns et les autres
ce qui a été versé à la place de la
passion voilà mes interventions
l'analyste dit v10 des plans s'il n'y a
pas d'autres intervenants
j'ajoute deux questions que je dois à la
sagacité d'une administratrice la
commission premièrement en matière de
violence la question de la détection et
du signalement est essentiel car souvent
les victimes sont réticentes à porter
plainte
comment améliorer les choses sur ce
point du site allemand de manière à
faciliter le dépôt de plainte de la part
de femmes qui parfois souvent n'osent
pas le faire
hellange une deuxième question le par
rapport à la parité
quelles dispositions envisagez vous pour
faire évoluer certaines pesanteurs
existant dans certains domaines
je pense en particulier aux fédérations
sportives où on nous explique dans
certains sports la parité n'est pas
possible et aussi à nos amis des
chambres d'agriculture il y a beaucoup
d'agricultrice dans ce pays et la parité
dans ce domaine pourrait tout à fait
être bénéfique comme dans les autres
domaines
madame la ministre s'il n'y a pas
d'autres interventions vous allez
pouvoir bénéficier de 24 minutes à peu
près pour répondre à ce flot de
questions qui montrera qui vous montre
l'intérêt de nos commissions de la
délégation pour votre projet de loi
merci mille fois à chacun de vous pour
ses interventions qu'ils me montrent que
vous vous êtes visiblement déjà bien
intéressé au projet de loi plutôt que de
reprendre vos interventions les unes
après les autres je vais faire des
réponses thématique puisque en plus vous
vous posiez souvent les mêmes questions
donc si on commence dans l'ordre vous
aviez une question sur la réforme du
congé parental enfin plusieurs vraiment
il faut que vous soyez absolument
convaincu j'espère que ça ne fait de
doute personne des objectifs et des
ambitions qui sont celles du
gouvernement avec cette réforme du congé
parental
personne n'a imaginé un instant que ce
serait une réforme facile à mener
et c'est forcément une réforme difficile
à construire parce que on revient sur
des choses existantes et il faut
toujours avoir ça à l'esprit par exemple
quand on nous dit souvent mais pourquoi
vous faites pas tout simplement comme la
suède où ils ont tout simplement un an
de congé parental mais mieux indemnisés
je réponds oui mais sauf que lorsque la
suède a construit son congé parental
d'un an bien indemnisés elle partait de
rien donc elle crée de nouveaux droits
c'était tout bénéfice d'une certaine
façon pour ce qui allait en bénéficier
nous nous partons d'une situation où
nous sommes pour les ménages avec deux
enfants est plus à une possibilité de
trois ans donc réduire de façon très
abrupte du jour au lendemain de 3 en un
an le congé parental c'était quand même
l'une des options qui était porté par un
certain nombre de spécialistes
ça nous paraissait très sévère donc le
choix que nous avons fait celui que je
vous ai décrit tout à l'heure il est
entièrement dicté par deux objectifs le
premier c'est de réduire l'éloignement
des femmes du marché du travail parce
qu'on sait bien que plus cet éloignement
et durable et plus le décrochage par
rapport au monde du travail est fort et
quand je dis décrochage par rapport au
monde du travail il faut aussi penser à
long terme c'est à dire y compris
pension de retraite
quelques années plus tard régularité
avec laquelle les femmes qui sortent du
congé parental se mettent en temps
partiel parce qu'il ya des habitudes qui
ont été prises or on sait tous autour de
la table qu'il faut qu'on lutte contre
ce temps partiel trop féminin et ses ex
et a donc réduire l'éloignement des
femmes du marché du travail donc cherché
à réduire d'une certaine façon ce temps
d'interruption d'activité pour elle et
le deuxième objectif mieux partagée
entre hommes et femmes jeunes et déjà
dit est la solution à laquelle nous
sommes arrivés et franchement la
meilleure à laquelle on pouvait arriver
compte tenu du contexte c'est à dire que
le contexte c'est quoi c'est que on a
bien en tête qu'il n'y a pas
suffisamment de mode de garde
aujourd'hui pour répondre à tous les
besoins des familles que le congé
parental malgré tout bien sert aussi à
à cela quoi prendre en charge son enfant
l'absence d'autres modes de garde mais
nous ne voulons pas que ces lapèze
exclusivement sur les épaules des femmes
alors nous instaurons cette période de
partage alors vous me direz mais c'est
difficile pour un homme du jour au
lendemain de demander six mois à son
employeur mais enfin ce sera quand même
plus facile pour lui
demain avec la loi parce qu'aujourd'hui
les hommes le demande
l'employeur leur fusil à une
stigmatisation sociale qui pèse sur les
hommes qui demande quelques mois de
congé parental l'employeur leur
répondant mais tape femme peut pas le
faire demain l'homme pourra dire mais
c'est la loi qui me l'imposent d'une
certaine façon on vient en coup de pouce
à ces hommes qui ont une vraie
revendication
deuxième chose à avoir l'esprit c'est
que on crée une incitation à prendre six
mois mais personne n'oblige à prendre
les six mois c'est très important
d'avoir en tête que tout ça est très
souple
par exemple les six mois en question
l'homme pour aller prendre un temps
partiel partageait avec sa femme pendant
une durée du congé parental
par exemple il peut prendre trois mois
au lieu de six mois tout comme
aujourd'hui une femme quand elle prend
son congé parental elle peut prendre six
mois ou 3 enfin je n'ai rien n'oblige à
prendre le congé parental dans sa
totalité
donc à une très grande souplesse qui
n'est peut-être pas suffisamment apparu
dans la présentation médiatique du
projet de loi mais qu'il faut que vous
ayez en tête
quant aux femmes elles mêmes ce qu'il
faut que vous ayez aussi en tête c'est
que ce projet de loi au fond ils
couvrent l'ensemble des enjeux c'est à
dire il s'agit pas simplement de dire
ont réduit leur éloignement ont fait
mieux partagée au père on s'intéresse
surtout ce que les pouvoirs publics ne
faisait pas jusqu'à présent au devenir
des femmes à la sortie du congé parental
en venant construire pour elle des
processus de formation d'accompagnement
de bilan de compétences etc pour ne pas
les laisser sur le bord du chemin je
pense en particulier à celles qui sont
en emploi parce que le clc à vous pouvez
en bénéficier sans être en emploi comme
vous le savez et qui à la sortie du clc
à se retrouve avec un taux de chômage
qui a doublé
donc c'est ça que nous introduisons
nouveau et sur la question de mais si
jamais le père le prend pas les prend
pas ces six mois et bien l'enfant ça va
se retrouver en difficulté
en attendant que commencent eux la
rentrée scolaire nous apportons
justement des réponses contrairement à
ce qui existait jusqu'à présent je vous
rappelle que ce qui existe jusqu'à
présent c'est que quand vous prenez
trois ans de congé parental les trois
ans du
jusque aux trois en âge de l'enfant et
non pas jusqu'à la rentrée scolaire dès
3 ans de l'enfant
vous savez donc si vous avez un enfant
qui est né au mois de janvier par
exemple et bien votre congé parental va
s'arrêter en janvier et la rentrée
scolaire de l'enfant ne sera que en
septembre suivant donc cette période ce
laps de temps de non réponse pour
l'enfant se poser aujourd'hui aux
familles or nous nous sommes en train
d'y apporter une réponse en faisant en
sorte de trouver une solution à la
jonction
c'est à dire en créant des mécanismes
dans lesquelles est bien on pourra quand
même mettre l'enfant pour six mois en
place de crèche parce qu'il y aura un
accompagnement personnalisé c'est à dire
qu'en fait le fait même de mener cette
réforme nous amène à répondre à des
questions qui se posaient déjà pour les
ménages auparavant auquel on n'apportait
pas de réponse est que désormais nous
parce qu'on a conscience que cette
réforme ne bouscule les habitudes
on va prendre en charge notamment par un
meilleur accompagnement
donc soit en place de très chaud pour
pour six mois soit en prêt scolarisation
en école maternelle c'est ce sur quoi
nous sommes en train de travailler quand
nous viendrons devant le sénat donc en
septembre nous aurons des propositions
précises sur ce sujet je pense que ça
répond à peu près aux questions qui
étaient posées sur le congé parental si
peut-être juste une chose parce que je
crois que c'était annie qui me posait la
question des 275 mille solutions
d'accueil annoncée par le premier
ministre et est ce que ça pourra
répondre et c'est faut bien avoir à
l'esprit que notre réforme du congé
parental s'agissant des comment dire des
familles de deux enfants et plus donc
qu'ils peuvent prendre trois ans de
congé parental et dans le cadre duquel
on insère cette prise de six mois par
les pairs elle ne produira des effets
que dans trois ans enfin dans deux ans
et demi puisque bien entendu cette
réforme là elle ne vaut pas pour les
enfants qui sont déjà là elle ne vaudra
qu'à partir du d'avril 2014 donc pour
les enfants qui vont naître à partir
d'avril 2014 donc il faut se projeter
finalement deux ans et demi après avril
2014 donc on aura quand même construit
un certain nombre des places de crèches
sur lesquels nous nous sommes engagés et
oui c'est ça peut être une
ce sera une réponse importante
sur fond oui sur le sujet de l'allemagne
pardon sur le sujet de l'allemagne il
faut bien voir parce que c'est pareil le
problème c'est que la présentation
médiatique des sujets parfois elles
troublent un petit peu et je comprends
et c'est important qu'on puisse répondre
à ceux enfin françaises et aux français
qu'ils peuvent s'inquiéter sur cette
réforme
en allemagne c'est vrai que l'indemnité
elle est d'à peu près 1000 euros si mes
souvenirs sont bons et ses 5000 euros et
que le congé parental du rhin en nous le
congé parental durent plus longtemps et
pour tout vous dire en allemagne il peut
durer plus longtemps mais avec une
indemnité qui du coup est dégressive
donc en fait quand vous prenez les
dispositifs qui existent en france on a
la même chose je pas si vous voyez ce
que c'est que le mécanisme du colca où
finalement les parents peuvent décider
au lieu de prendre trois ans de congé
parental de n'en prendre qu'un an mais
avec une indemnité plus importante qui a
atteint quasiment les seuls 900 euros à
peu près donc on est en fait on a les
mêmes mécanismes
c'est assez comparable voilà donc c'est
ça et c'est vrai que par ailleurs
l'allemagne nous a inspiré sur les
résultats qu'ils ont obtenus avec leurs
réformes parce que mine de rien à eux
aussi en 2007 quand ils ont adopté cette
réforme où ils prévoient donc une bonne
qu'une partie du congé parental elle
sera prise par le père est sinon perdue
en 2007 quand ils ont adopté on leur a
dit mais ils font jamais s'y mettre vous
êtes fous ça fait pas partie de la
culture etc
eh ben il est il était à 3 % d'hommes
qui prenait le congé parental en 2007
après la réforme
trois ans plus tard il était à 20 %
d'hommes donc c'est quand même assez
intéressant et ça donne des idées de ce
qu'on pourrait réaliser nous aujourd'hui
on estime qu'il ya dix huit mille hommes
qui prennent une partie de congé
parental on espère en atteindre 100
milles d'ici trois ans voilà sur la
question des violences
je veux juste que vous ayez aussi une
chose en tête
tout n'est pas dans la loi c'est
vraiment important parce que c'est vrai
que par exemple la question des places
d'hébergement pour les victimes de
violences
c'est pas écrit dans la loi mais on l'a
déjà acté on a acté qu'on allait
construire 1500 places d'hébergement
d'urgence pour les femmes victimes de
violences de la même façon il ya un
certain nombre de dispositifs qui
existent déjà pour les auteurs de
violences et on a réussi à ont
répertorié plus d'une 140 dispositifs
qui existent au niveau national pour les
auteurs de violences donc en même temps
pour répondre à la virginie toutes les
études nous démontre qu'en fait les
auteurs ils ont un réseau amical sociale
et c'est plus important que les victimes
donc il faut pas forcément mettre les
deux sur le même plan mais mais c'est un
sujet qu'on traite et notamment avec
l'ami prof la mission interministérielle
pour la protection des femmes qui
construit donc un certain nombre de
dispositifs sur toujours les violences
alors l'extension de l' ordonnance de
protection donc aux enfants moi je les
noter je pense qu'il faut juste qu'on
s'assure de la constitutionalité
peut-être de la mesure avant de la
glisser dans le texte
parce que en fait voyez-les ordonnance
de protection c'est quand même
comment dire c'est un peu exorbitant de
droit commun comme comme procédure donc
moi je me dit un jour si c'est le
conseil constitionnel s'en saisissent et
qui se mettaient à la détricoter se
ferait pas terrible donc faut 4 et enfin
voilà il faut bien peser ce qu'on y met
pour faire en sorte quand même de
respecter les libertés publiques mais je
comprends très bien ce qu'ils te guide
dans cette idée donc avoir à expertiser
j'ai bien noté la question sur la
question du secret professionnel et la
frontière avec l'année en assistance à
personne en danger
moi si vous pouvez avancer sur ce sujet
ça m'intéresse de voir ce que vous
proposerez mais c'est clair que c'est un
enjeu majeur
d'ailleurs on pourrait s'inspirer de ce
qui existe en matière de protection de
l'enfance parce que finalement et je dis
pas que c'est forcément exactement
copiable comme mécanisme mais mais on
fait des choses intéressantes en ce
domaine sur les violences je crois à oui
les délais il ya les délais donc oui on
écrit nous meilleurs délais en fait on
l'a écrit comme ça après avoir écouté
beaucoup de professionnels alors je sais
plus je crois que l'une d'entre vous la
fait remarquer aussi mais professionnels
sont divisés sur ce sujet donc le délai
pour délivrer l'ordonnancé de protection
nous on a envie clairement que la règle
ils deviennent une semaine de pour
délivrer cette ordonnance de protection
mais certains professionnels nous disent
que y compris pour la femme elle même
avoir une date butoir qui tombe un peu
comme un couperet
c'est un peu quitte ou double vous voyez
si jamais voilà exactement si jamais
celle leurs danses de protection n'a pas
été prise d'une certaine façon bas c'est
trop tard après sept jours donc on nous
a plutôt convaincu d'écrire meilleurs
délais quitte à être peut être plus
précis dans le décret d'application et à
organiser en tout cas dans le décret
d'application les conditions d'une plus
grande célérité c'est à dire un
véritable partenariat entre les acteurs
parce que c'est là où ça a marché
concrètement c'est parce que il ya ce
partenariat entre les associations le
barreau le tribunal
et c'est donc un protocole systématique
qui pourrait s'imposer un peu partout et
puis l'une des choses qu'on pourrait
améliorer aussi c'est faire en sorte ce
sera dans le décret d'application que ce
soit systématiquement par pli d'huissier
qu'on convoque la partie défenderesse ce
qui irait plus vite sur les violences
il reste mon ski a été posée à les
signalements ah oui d'accord pardon oui
monsieur le président vous aviez une
question sur les violences comment est
ce qu'on peut améliorer les signalements
puisqu'on estime que seulement une femme
sur dix dépose plainte d'abord il n'ya
pas que le dépôt de plainte et il ya une
chose à laquelle on s'est attachés c'est
la question des mains courantes puisque
clairement il ya beaucoup de femmes qui
se rendent dans un commissariat mais qui
ne laisse qu'une main courante et on
refuse qu'elles continuent à être des
bouteilles vides jetées à la mer donc en
fait on a c'est pas dans la loi là
encore c'est hors loi mais c'est par le
biais d'une circulaire qu'on a signé
récemment
donc il va être signée pardon mais en
tout cas elle est déjà rédigé dans
laquelle on installe une procédure
d'enfin dans tous les tribunaux pour que
faire en sorte que le procureur se
fassent remonter systématiquement les
mains courantes et que celle qui lui
semble particulièrement alarmante fasse
l'objet d'un suivi
c'est à dire que la victime qui est venu
déposer cette main courante soir contact
et méthodiquement par une assistante
sociale qui demande à la voir pour
vérifier l'évolution de la situation
donc c'est un sujet qu'on a en tête
je crois qu'il faut que j'aille beaucoup
plus vite donc blabla juste sur
l'égalité salariale parce que ses
revenus à plusieurs reprises
oui il faut l'écrire en tant que tel
c'est vrai et de fait on va l'écrire
parce que pour répondre à la question
dany qui me demandait ce qu'on va mettre
non dany je crois annie david qui me
demandait ce qu'on va reprendre de
l'accord des partenaires sociaux delà de
l'accord des partenaires sociaux
en gros on va reprendre tout ce qui
concerne la dynamisation des
négociations et non pas pour les vider
de leur substance du formation tout de
suite parce que je sais qu'il ya eu un
flottement au moment de la négociation
de cet accord mais pour juste qu'elle
soit moins formel et plus effective plus
efficace on va reprendre ce qui concerne
l'accompagnement des salariés revenant
de congé parental et on va introduire
quelque chose sur les classifications
c'est à dire en gros la revalorisation
des métiers à prédominance féminine qui
est un sujet à part entière et alors
pourquoi je fais le lien entre les deux
questions parce que justement dans la
mesure qu'on introduira sur les
classifications
on fera en sorte de remettre par écrit
la définition exacte de ce qu'on entend
par travail un travail de valeur égale
salaire égal et donc ce faisant on
reparlera d'égalité salariale à
proprement parler c'est à dire qu'en
gros on précisera bien dans la loi qui a
deux
niveau qu'il faut bien avoir à l'esprit
à travail égal salaire égal à travail de
valeur égale salaire égal et ont donc
donc on avancera sur ce sujet on fera
des propositions et puis je sais qu'il
ya d'autres mesures qui ont été
proposées notamment par la cgt sur
l'histoire du droit d' expertise du
comité d'entreprise
s'agissant du rapport de situation
comparée qui nous semble être une bonne
idée qu'ont qu'il faudrait introduire
donc ça si vous voulez le porter non non
non non voilà pour finir sur la parité
les questions qui m'étaient posées sur
la parité en gros il faut retenir que là
encore on a voulu à la fois fixé un
principe ferme
en même temps on est relativement
pragmatique parce que tu disais il ya
des moments où la sociologie permet pas
par exemple dans une fédération sportive
d'atteindre les 50% dans la
représentation c'est juste c'est pour ça
que par exemple s'agissant des
fédérations sportives
on a fait en sorte de distinguer celles
où la sociologie fait apparaître moins
de 25% d'un même sexe -2 25% par exemple
de femme à celle là on ne demande que
d'atteindre 25% dans les instances
dirigeantes d'ici 2020 alors que celle
où la sociologie fait apparaître plus de
25% du sexe féminin par exemple nous
savons aussi dans l'autre sens on
demande d'atteindre 50 % d'ici 2020 donc
on fait quand même une distinction pour
être et s'agissant des chambres de
commerce et d'industrie on fixe à peu
près dé c'est à peu près équivalents ce
que je viens de dire c'est à dire que
l'on tient compte de la réalité pour pas
non plus être blackboulé on veut
vraiment que ce soit effectif tout ça et
je dirais un dernier mot avant de vous
lâcher sur tout ce qui a été dit sur
l'éducation et je vous remercie
enfin vous avez été plusieurs à
l'évoquer c'est évidemment majeur là
encore tout n'est pas dans la loi je
vous rappelle que par exemple on va
expérimenter ça y est c'est
définitivement partie à la rentrée
scolaire en septembre
cet apprentissage nouveau en petite
classe donc fin maternelle jusqu'à fin
primaire qui s'appelle les abcd de
l'égalité qui va vraiment être prendre à
la racine la question de l'égalité
filles garçons
ouvrir les appétences les compétences
des unes et des autres la confiance en
soi etc
c'est très important il ya 600
établissements scolaires qui ont accepté
de s'engager dans la démarche donc c'est
en septembre que ça commence à voir la
généralisation à tous les établissements
scolaires
il ya en effet une connexion à faire je
crois que c'est brigitte qui évoquait sa
avec la loi sur la refondation de
l'école n'est pas seulement aussi la loi
sur l'enseignement supérieur la
recherche donc et notamment par la
question de la formation des formateurs
dans des nouvelles écoles supérieures du
professorat dans lesquels désormais est
prévu un module de formation à l'égalité
filles garçons
là ça je les dis ah oui pardon j'ai
oublié mais bon enfin sur la question de
l'éducation pour finir si vous avez
d'autres propositions même si on va pas
refaire le débat sur la loi refondation
de l'école mais mais voilà je sais un
sujet d'évidence
crucial si on s'attaque à la racine des
inégalités et d'ailleurs j'en profite
pour vous dire que j'ai oublié une chose
dans ma présentation de la loi tout à
l'heure c'est qu'on passe aussi par
internet comme ça on aura vraiment
parler de tout ce qui forge les
mentalités écoles média internet il ya
une ou deux mesures dans la loi
n'hésitez pas un les voiliers et sur
internet d'ailleurs espère je sais que
c'est un sujet qui t'intéresse aussi
n'hésitez pas à compléter si vous avez
des choses qu'on peut mettre donc là
nous ce qu'on fait c'est complète les
dispositions de la loi sur l'économie
numérique celle à lcn qui n'avait pas
prévu le cas de sexisme dans ce qui
pouvait être signalée par les
internautes donc on complète dans la loi
si vous avez d'autres suggestions sur ce
sujet on peut y aller on est juste le
sexisme et pour finir sur les pensions
alimentaires donc s'agissant de
l'insolvabilité organisée très bonne
question qui vaut pour tous les
territoires dont on a parfaitement
conscience
en fait aujourd'hui c'est ce que on
qualifie dans notre droit de situations
de hors d'état à chaud rs plus loin
d'état c'est à dire des débiteurs dont
on considère que de toute façon ils sont
pas en situation de payer leurs fins sur
l'alimentaire donc on leur cours même pu
après pour qu'il la paye et dans cette
catégorie de hors d'état on met les gens
qu'ils soient ont des très faibles
revenus genre son rsa soit les gens qui
ont disparu à l'étranger et donc on
retrouve plus soit les auteurs de
violences conjugales et moi m'ont donc
mon idée c'est de dire que on peut pas
juste les exonérer tous ces gens là de
leurs obligations
donc on repousse cette catégorie hors
d'état ça fait partie de
l'expérimentation qui va être mené par
la caf qui s'engagent dans ce sujet
pension alimentaire
on repousse cette catégorie comme en bas
en faisant en sorte par exemple pour les
auteurs de violences conjugales
certes ça pouvait se justifier qu'on
leur cours pas particulièrement après
quand c'était à la mère de le faire
parce qu'on voulait pas mettre la mer
face à asson sa vie que son bourreau
mais désormais puisque c'est la caf qui
fait écran alors la caf doit lui courir
après pour recouvrer son dû
s'agissant du rsa enfin de ceux qui sont
à des très faibles revenus et notamment
rsa on préférera leur faire payer
quelques dizaines d'euros que rien du
tout donc on le fera quand même
et s'agissant du de ceux qui
disparaissent à l'étranger il ya une
convention un texte international qui
s'appelle la convention de la haye qui a
été signée par la france est donc là on
mène une diplomatie très active pour la
faire signer par les pays qui nous
entourent dans lesquels on remarque que
souvent les débiteurs défaillants vont
se réfugier et qui permet une
coopération judiciaire pour faire payer
donc cette pension alimentaire même si
la personne est à l'étranger
voilà je crois que monsieur sûr essayé
de m'arrêter depuis tout à l'heure en
soupirant de façon de plus en plus
évident madame la ministre je ne soupire
pas
ce n'est pas mon style d'abord je ne
soupire pas du tout ensuite je n'essaie
pas de vous arrêter et ensuite je suis
très intéressé par vos propos comme
toujours
et enfin comme nous devons rejoindre il
vous même aussi madame la ministre
les questions d'actualité et que vous
devez leur monter l'escalier de manière
digne digne voilà sans excès de rapidité
mais avec quand même la vigueur qui sied
à notre jeunesse collective afin je
parle là en avançant peut-être un peu
s'agissant de moi même je voulais badham
la ministre au nom de dany david et de
brigitte gonthier maurin en mon nom
propre et au nom bien sûr de tous nos
collègues vous remercier sincèrement
pour la qualité de vos réponses 1
puisque je crois que vous avez réussi à
répondre à toutes les questions
cela va nous enrichir pour la
préparation des rapports puisque nous
étudions cela en séance en commission
des lois la semaine prochaine et puis
comme cela nous aurons tout le mois
d'août pour méditer vos propos de
manière à dès l'ouverture de la session
de septembre
être en pleine forme pour vous retrouver
aborder ce texte
je vous remercie voilà vous avez pu
suivre l'audition de najat vallaud
belkacem devant la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat la ministre
des droits des femmes présentaient le
projet de loi pour lutter contre les
inégalités persistantes entre femmes et
hommes
ce texte sera examiné à partir de
septembre au sénat